okay so for for bipolar there is a list
of uh symptoms if you're in an episode
uh I think you have to have four of
these coexisting this Confluence of
symptoms happening at any one time you
can be in a bad mood or you can be
irritable or you can have Reckless
suspending or you can be Los you know
you can be kind of having insomnia all
those things that are telltale signs of
mania um they can be happening I I had a
really hard time sleeping two nights ago
and it you know it's concerning
that's a big red flag man when I stop
like when I stop sleeping for no reason
that usually is a sign that Mania is on
the way one of the weirdest you want to
know one of the weirdest things that
that is a symptom for me of um Mania if
I if I wake up one day and like three
pairs of shoes show up I know that I'm
we're well into a mixed episode I don't
even know what dude I didn't even know I
bought shoes the other day